is probably oversimplifying things but
sometimes when when teams play against
the old kids you turn them into a score
you turn them into a pass or any
controls the game he only had four
assists tonight yeah that's a ridiculous
you know it's just
that's the untrained eye that says
something like that this guy's an
incredible player you know twice in two
seasons he's been the best player on
this planet
you can't just say oh make him a score
that's not how they play they they have
so many different actions that just get
you compromised uh
we have to focus on what we do
um you know we try to do things the hard
way and he requires you to do many
things the hard way
man we he has our full respect okay
thank you thank you coach